when you have a look at this diagram um
it's a bit tricky because you start to
get lost in
you see why now i didn't put on any more
labels because it's it's
already pretty confusing okay the first
thing you've got to do
is you've got to try and get theta in
the picture you've got to get thinner in
the picture so you can do your signs and
causes and trigonometry just like we did
over here
okay i think you can probably see for
instance if i go from theta to here
right see this angle this is a 90 degree
angle because it's
the intersection between the horizontal
and vertical
forces right so being that's a 90 degree
angle this is 90 minus theta
but this is 90 over here that's also a
right angle so you've got 90 90 minus
theta that leaves theta up here does
that make sense
so you should have it up there in the
same way that i did alternate angles in
this diagram
you've got theta over there as well okay
so if you went ahead and drew your
triangles carefully
what you would have found is you've got
this
component going along the normal and
then you've got where am i going to
write it
up here this component
going along the tangent okay so now
we have all of the pieces we have a
counter for the horizontal we accounted
for the vertical
and now we can add everything up okay so
we're in a uniform motion okay
let's think about the normal first the
normal because they're both kind of
headed in the same direction does that
make sense
now when you're doing the normal all you
have to do is add up
okay well i've got f y sine
theta and it's positive because it's
going away from the origin
and then you've got f y sorry f x
cos theta right so that's all good but i
know what f y and f x
are i spent all that time developing
that table going all the way from
displacement
differentiate all the way down multiply
by mass what do you get
what is f y times sine theta
and if my memory is certainly i think
you should get minus
m r omega squared
i think and then this one was cos theta
so you're going to get sine theta cos
theta
isn't that what i did what have i got oh
right sorry it's squared
i'm thinking of the other one i'm doing
the wrong way
better cool you play the same kind of
thing
with your horizontal force multiplied by
cos theta so you're getting this
cos squared okay and you're like hold on
hold on
sine squared plus cos squared just a
pythagorean there
so these both add up to one right
so then what are you getting you're just
getting minus m
r omega squared now just pause for a
second
do you remember when we played our game
and considered
the vector in one spot and then the
vector in another spot we added them up
together
and then we compared the change we found
the acceleration was pointing toward
the origin right and that was kind of
like a nice fancy geometric trick
but have a look at this can you see why
this tells you exactly the same thing
right this negative sign means being
this away from the center is the
positive direction
then the negative means you're going
back in that direction
okay so along this axis
that's the force on the normal okay it's
pushing you back toward the center the
word we had for that was centripetal
remember that
okay let's have a look at the tangent
now right
so be careful with this one though
because your horizontal force right
you see how it contributes this force
but it's going in the wrong direction
right it's going down this way okay so
therefore what you're going to have
is f i'm sure right this right f y cos t
that's going in the positive direction
but then you're going to subtract
f x sine theta is that right does that
make sense
okay now this is what i was thinking of
before because f y
has the sign in it when you multiply by
cos that's going to give you minus
m r omega squared sine cos
right then you subtract because it's
going in the other direction
but then when you just substitute this
in you've got another minus
right and it'll be m r omega squared
it'll also be sine theta
cos theta right okay so what does this
mean
it means these two exactly cancel each
other out these two are going in
opposite directions
in the same magnitude right so your
force along that tangential axis
is zero why is that
because the whole scenario we started
with
was that omega is a constant right
so i'm going around at a constant rate
i'm not speeding up as i go around i'm
not slowing down
i'm just going around at a uniform rate
so there's no
force along this tangent axis that's
speeding me up or slowing me down
right if this was positive i'd be going
faster and faster faster
if it was negative i'd be getting slower
and slower and slower okay
so a couple of things before we leave
off uniform motion
you might notice you've got your omega
there right that means that
how long does it take me to go all the
way around
in other words what's the period of
motion because that's how long it takes
me
to get back to the beginning you can get
this straight from omega
right how far do you have to go to make
one full revolution
answer two pi radians right
period right this is time this is
distance
over speed right but speed is
omega that's how fast i'm going around
right
so that's the period okay in exactly the
same way
you can say what's the frequency
how would you work out frequency from
that
think about it
how do we usually go you know when you
think of trig functions right
these guys
which by the way are exactly the same as
what you have here okay
how do you go from period to frequency
period to frequency
one over it's just isn't it just the
reciprocal of this it's just the
reciprocal of this
it'll be omega over two pi now it's not
that you have to
remember those for me personally my
brain goes immediately
here rather than here but the questions
will equally give you either
it'll say it goes around frequency up
here 500 whatever's per minute or
something like that
or they'll tell you it takes me 15
seconds to go all the way around so
you'll see both of them okay so that's
the last thing i'm going to say about
uniform circulation before i give you an
example
i want to mention non-uniform circular
motion before we leave off because
there's a bunch of questions which are
just like this
but rather than omega being
some kind of constant right what they
say is well omega can change
right or maybe you can speed up or slow
down right
now think about it like this
how do we get to these forces how do we
get to here right
well i can do a bit of a shortcut for
you remember when we did our diagram
we said that velocity we just went from
the arc length formula
right the velocity along the
tangent is equal to now i think remember
this right
i've got it written down here it's just
going to be r times omega
right does that make sense and that's
how we got that the further you were
away from the center
you know like that poor person on the
outside of the circle okay the faster
you had to run
right because this gets bigger all right
so how would you go
to acceleration along the tangent if
omega was not
a constant if it were a function
now i'm not telling you what the
function is it could be anything right
but the point is well r's going to be a
constant so i'm just going to chuck that
out the front
okay and then you're differentiating
with respect to time
you're doing this make sense to get to a
force
you know this kind of thing right the
force along the tangent is just going to
be this multiplied by mass
okay now in order to maintain its
circularness okay so that i don't spiral
in
and like you know sort of crash into the
origin or do the reverse
not have enough force holding me and so
that i just you know i go off and i i
don't stay within orbit i suppose
okay what you can say is that this is
the force along the tangent well the
force along the normal
has to be exactly the same as this
it has to be the same if it's not
exactly precisely equal to that
you won't get a circle okay and this um
this circular
motion right that force that you get
it can result from a whole variety of
things that's pulling you back toward
the center for instance
it could be now pause for a second
think about this think about this okay
what's the force
keeping the keys in circular motion
because there's a force keeping them
there
otherwise they wouldn't do this right
i'm trying the best as i can to make it
uniform okay
so we've got this zero force okay what's
holding it in
hmm now we don't usually think of it in
these terms right but this
um this lanyard right this lanyard is
exerting a force
okay now just consider this um at the
moment
i can't oh here we go i'll do it like
this right
at the moment this lanyard is not
exerting any force
right because it's um nothing's
nothing's holding it tight okay
but the second i do this the lane
goes out straight right now we have a
name for that we call that tension
okay there's tension in the what's it
called in the lanyard right
if there's no tension if it was like say
um what's a what's a substance which has
an attention like something like plato
or something
it would just stretch out and it would
go forever the force that's pulling
um this out right because you know how
there's this force
right what was the third law of our
motion
there's gonna be an equal and opposite
force going in the other direction
right so some people call that
centrifugal force right so that reaction
force is trying to pull away
okay so there's no tension in the
lanyard it'll just fly off
okay so i should watch this more
carefully but there is tension in the
string
okay in the lanyard and that's this
tension here
it's holding it in circular motion and
by the way there's plenty of other
things we know in our common experience
uh even if we don't
i mean we see them up in the sky what
other kinds of things are going to hold
things in circular motion
things like say gravity right so that's
holding things
like i know you know if i put an earth
here
there's an earth okay um this thing is
exerting that force along the normal and
that's gravity we're familiar with that
right so this force or that force it's
the same thing
okay you can get it from gravity you can
get it from tension
and you can get it from a few other
places as well that we're going to
notice in
the following week okay but that's the
important thing that's what this
represents
okay